that's right you remember a very first
lesson together I showed you a video do
you remember what the video is about do
you remember we sat down I showed it to
you if you don't remember it's all about
the fact that maths is bad
matt is patterns so it starts a yeah
yeah that's right
channel 4 so it's all about all you know
like a snowflake look at the pattern of
it and you can describe it
mathematically or look at the noise that
comes with oh and a train door closes
where you can describe all that noise
mathematically and I'm not I'm not okay
and the cool things have happened is
that once you recognize a pattern when
you recognize a pattern well yes but why
okay you can follow the pattern in
places where can I say this like in the
future you can predict things you can
you can understand how things work if
you don't pattern okay now let me give
an example I was reading I was reading
the newspaper the other day and this is
just something over my head so maybe did
you test a bit funny but I'm pretty sure
it said something like astronomers have
discovered a planet orbiting some star
somewhere out there and the composition
of its atmosphere very similar to the
composition of Earth's atmosphere
nitrogen this oxygen that it's all in
silver so that was kind of cool right
but then well he was my question here's
my question how do they know that like
all this stuff about that this fear and
all that kind of thing well maybe I
don't know this is there's green and
blue stuff that doesn't have to do with
like I could chuck this into space and
it would still be the same greeny bluey
sort of color that's here
well no but no no you know not that far
off I mean we're looking at these
planets through a telescope no one's
ever been there but they recognize a
pattern
like it's something about the chemicals
and they give off certain radiation
light wavelengths and so on and because
they do that they understand what the
planet is like even if you'd have been
there
they'd have to could fly there and
measure they know the pattern so they
can say something about that planet even
having never me man okay
now we're gonna have a look at a similar
kind of idea when we think about angles
and parallel lines okay but first let's
just introduce two terms okay or
reintroduce run up so let's get some
definitions here firstly now here's what
I'm gonna ask you to do I actually want
you to write a sentence for me okay and
it starts off like this power legs ah
and what are they how would you define
them I reckon where you get a few
different definitions here probably a
few that are valid if you've been taught
some will be better than others let me
just give you about 30 seconds so have a
think about write something down onto
your board someone who's never heard of
what parallel lines are how would you
explain define what they are to that
person write down write it down write
down you please make up and I'll get
everyone to UM give me their suggestions
in about any way okay all right I reckon
it's bad enough time let me hear some
definitions parallel lines are someone
want to give a suggestion oh yeah whoa
opposites let's put that one down
you got something different lines that
never be true lines it never me does
anyone have something different again
that's
lenz I read it a little okay but that's
kind of yeah I would hurt the parallel
lines are lines that run that's right
that run I suppose that begs the
question what does Carlo me there's
everyone something is different again
okay yeah okay okay let's have a think
about this now I think we're on to
something here um why does it run in
parallel I'm gonna give I'm gonna give
that what it takes because I think
hopefully by definition that is true
parallel lines are always straight
because you were thinking about lines
that don't they're they don't band or
wave around that kind of thing okay
opposites
I suppose this depends on what you mean
by opposite I'm gonna come back to sew
on a second now I think this is yours
eighty right and I think Chloe you
wouldn't say there's anything lines that
never meet okay so I have a question for
you I know I can't have an infinite line
like I can't draw one but I can have
part of the line and that represents the
whole picture
imagine them stretching your forever got
two nights now let me ask you this
question okay you have a look with me
here we go okay if these are two lines
are these lines ever going to meet
where's this one gonna go this one's
going to go back into the whiteboard
right and then out through that window
okay that one next to the door okay this
one is gonna go down through the
whiteboard and then off up into our
window okay these are these aren't gonna
meet are they forever
right but would you call these parallel
lines yeah well if we just stick with
this definition lines never mean you'd
call these parallel now see this is
where we come at it okay now hold on a
second
how about how are these two words add
these parallels I assume your morning
appreciate yeah right
how about if I move it here still yes
but what are this
now I came to he's he's the important
thing this lines that never meet right
is I think it's the start I think the
first half our definition but it seems
like we shouldn't call these things
parallel because then they're not you
know they're not running together in any
sense they're completely going off in
different directions right I think it
has something to do this I think we're
on the right track here
what does opposite mean anyway opposites
is actually we give this the other day
with another class another word that's a
bit like opposite is uh you know
opponent opponent or opposition what
does that mean it means the other side
it means they're armed they're against
you or facing you right now in what
sense are these lines parallel but these
aren't yeah these guys aren't really
facing each other are they where's these
ones
ah okay now I still like this idea here
sorry lines that never meet I want to
take that as our start but I want to use
language that you got is nerd which we
can sort of make it a little specific
okay so I'm going to say parallel ones
off why is that never meet but okay no
I'm just gonna write this down and then
you see if I can explain it okay but I'm
on the same plane okay no I don't mean a
flying plane I mean up I mean a flat
surface okay this is empathy now now
that these lines are on here okay these
lines are not parallel cuz they'll hit
they will mean eventually right but
these lines work and they on the same
plane so these are parallel now if I
take one of them off like this and face
it out toward you these lines are still
not going to meet but they're not
parallel because they're not on the same
play and they're not on the same then on
the whiteboard or I could go again I
could say you know he's the table he's
another plane I can put lines on there
that don't meet and only goes on to
power if I come off the table
like standing up okay it's not gonna
meet but it's not parallel okay all
right that's parallel lines we need one
more word to be able to describe
something in relation to these because
seeing as parallel lines never make
they're kind of boring actually it's
like can you imagine a movie in the two
characters they never meet they never
interact with each other it's like great
great great relationship character
develop they're right
paralyzed on the road not that
interesting but when you get a line that
goes across both parallel lines and we
call them transversals okay then
interesting stuff have interesting
patterns happen okay so transversals are
well a transversal is sorry I should say
that a transversal is a line it will
always do is cross the other two
parallel lines that crosses two I
suppose you could do more if you like
two or more parallel lines